[Música]
tuvo lugar la primera audiencia de la
comisión que investiga los hechos de la
insurrección del 6 de enero en la ciudad
de washington que fue calificada como un
ataque planificado y coordinado la
atención estuvo en los testimonios de
cuatro policías que evidenciaron la
violencia de la turba impulsada por el
ex presidente de donald trump
el presidente interino de perú francisco
sagasti dio un mensaje de despedida a
los peruanos en el que agradeció el
apoyo para enfrentar la pandemia de kobe
19 le aseguro que faltaron muchas cosas
por hacer
sagasti termina el mandato con el 52 por
ciento de aprobación pedro castillo su
sucesor que tomará posesión del cargo
mañana enfrenta retos históricos
y el brasileño ítalo ferreira se llevó
el oro en surf un deporte que debuta en
estas justas olímpicas de tokio 2020
ferreira de origen humilde desafía los
cánones de los surfistas brasileños
muchos de ellos acaudalados y de piel
clara un deporte que muchos denuncian
hay discriminación
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález en washington en eeuu comenzó
este martes la investigación
parlamentaria sobre el asalto al
capitolio del pasado 6 de enero un
ataque en el que 140 agentes de la
policía resultaron heridos y en el que
murieron cinco personas entre ellas
precisamente un agente son ellos sólo
cuatro de ellos los que asistieron a
esta primera sesión y allí han
testificado sobre largas horas en las
que defendieron al congreso entre estos
fuertes declaraciones o emociones por
parte de los agentes que recordaron los
insultos y las agresiones que padecieron
y que lamentaron la fractura que hay a
nivel nacional en informes de rosa pérez
en el mismo lugar de los hechos arrancó
este martes la investigación
parlamentaria sobre el ataque al
capitolio del 6 de enero cuando cientos
de seguidores del entonces presidente de
donald trump quisieron impedir la
confirmación de la victoria electoral de
joe biden en la primera sesión de la
comisión bipartidista creada por la
cámara de representantes- cuatro
policías revivieron el que pensaron iba
a ser su último momento y notaba que me
faltaba el oxígeno me recuerdo
diciéndome a mí mismo
así es como voy a morir defendiendo esta
entrada
los agentes coincidieron en la necesidad
de llegar a la cima de la cadena de
responsabilidades sobre el ataque en
alusiones claras al expresidente trump
el tiempo el lugar y las circunstancias
de este ataque la retórica y lo
acontecido para mí señala en dirección a
nuestro presidente y a otros miembros no
solo del congreso también del senado
acusaciones políticas que el propio
congresista adam kinzinger uno de los
dos únicos republicanos que integran la
comisión compartió como muchos
estadounidenses estoy frustrado porque
seis meses después de que una
insurrección mortal irrumpió en el
capitolio durante varias horas todavía
no sepamos lo que pasó porque porque
muchas personas de mi partido han
tratado de esto como si fuera solo otra
discusión partidista los nueve miembros
de la comisión fueron elegidos por la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes la demócrata nancy pelosi
que impidió que los fieles seguidores de
trump participaran en ella
a la radical de los republicanos
considera la investigación una farsa
pero la indagación parlamentaria se
desarrolla en paralelo a la policial 500
personas han sido interpeladas por su
participación en el asalto la mayoría se
delataron a sí mismas al alardear de sus
acciones en redes sociales
el presidente y te vino y saliente de
perú francisco sagasti de un mensaje de
despedida de los ciudadanos peruanos
después de ocho meses de estar en el
mandato en el que tuvo una aprobación
del 52% en su mensaje
sagasti agradeció el apoyo de los
peruanos en los momentos desafiantes que
vivió este país como la pandemia del cob
y 19 el mandatario de transición también
afirmó que si bien hubo muchos avances
el camino por recorrer es todavía muy
largo para alcanzar las metas que lleven
a mejorar las condiciones de vida de los
peruanos pedro castillo asumirá la
jefatura del estado este miércoles con
desafíos a los que ningún otro
presidente ha tenido que hacer frente un
sistema de salud completamente arrasado
una economía golpeada la oposición en el
parlamento y un plan de vacunación que
avanza muy lentamente
natalia plazas nos cuenta más en su
informe
[Música]
al nuevo presidente de perú le esperan
varios retos pedro castillo ha hecho
promesas ambiciosas modificar la
constitución para cambiar la economía o
sacar al país de la pandemia pero sus
promesas son tan grandes como los
obstáculos que le esperan la economía
del país ha caído en picado en 2020 el
pib se desplomó en un 11% y la pandemia
ha agudizado la desigualdad en un país
donde casi el 60 por ciento de las
personas en las ciudades tienen trabajos
informales según el banco mundial la
pobreza no ha dejado de crecer desde
2016 y ya en 2019 afectaba al 20,2 por
ciento de la población en cuanto al
coronavirus perú es el país con la mayor
tasa de mortalidad por cada 100.000
habitantes en todo el mundo y la
vacunación avanza a un ritmo lento sin
embargo castillo ha prometido aumentar
la atención en cuidados intensivos
proveer más oxígeno y vacunar a todos
los mayores de 18 años antes de que
termine 2021 pero hay un reto más uno
que definirá todo su mandato se trata de
su libertad para gobernar en medio de un
afuera
posición en el parlamento el partido del
castillo pero libre tiene tan solo 37 de
sus 130 escaños los últimos gobiernos
han enfrentado una dura oposición
principalmente del fujimorismo y nada
garantiza que su mandato dure sólo en el
último quinquenio hubo cuatro
presidentes castillo ha llamado a la
unión pero las recientes elecciones
mostraron una fuerte división política
con 18 candidatos a la presidencia en la
primera vuelta de la habilidad de
castillo para crear lazos políticos
dependerá no sólo su futuro en la
presidencia sino también que perú salga
de la crisis política y deje atrás la
pandemia en otros temas el gobierno de
eeuu anunció este martes que pondrá en
pausa cierta cooperación con el
ministerio público de guatemala después
de la destitución la semana pasada de
juan francisco sandoval el jefe de la
unidad anticorrupción la portavoz del
departamento de estado ya link a porter
dijo que el cambio y la puesta en pausa
afectará a la cooperación ya coordinada
con el ministerio público después de que
washington apoyará abiertamente a
sandoval
en el desarrollo de varias
investigaciones contra ex funcionarios
también ex presidentes y líderes
empresariales en guatemala
washington calificó este despido de
sandoval como una falta de compromiso
con el derecho de estar
ítalo ferreira le dio a brasil la
primera medalla de oro en surf un
deporte que está debutando en esta
edición de los juegos olímpicos tokio
2020 ferreira es hijo de un pescador del
estado de río grande del norte una de
las zonas más pobres de ese país
suramericano y él desafía los cánones
del surf brasileño usualmente practicado
por personas blancas y acaudaladas un
deporte que no escapa a las denuncias de
discriminación
entre la playa de ipanema y la favela de
cantagalo no hay solamente un enjambre
de callejones un abismo social y racial
separa el mundo del sur del podio
olímpico anderson es conocido como
pikachu comenzó a surfear a los 4 años
cuando iba a la playa con su abuela muy
pronto se dio cuenta de que tenía un don
por la tabla
las personas del mundo del surf en río
de janeiro empezaron a apoyar mi
evolución en 2013 tuve la oportunidad de
viajar a hawai fue uno de los mejores
viajes de mi vida
a pesar de haber ganado varios torneos
locales picacho encuentra dificultades
para conseguir patrocinios el color de
su piel cuenta mucho a la hora de atraer
a las marcas y eso a pesar de que
algunos de los mejores surfistas del
mundo son brasileños como acaba de
quedar patente en tokio con el triunfo
de italo ferreira las empresas no
quieren patrocinar a los jóvenes de la
favela prefieren patrocinar a los chicos
blancos de ojos azules aquí aquí en río
nosotros que nos dedicamos al surf
sufrimos el racismo en nuestras propias
carnes
erika tuvo que lidiar con ese mismo
problema desde la primera competición
supo que quería dedicarse a este deporte
pero no tuvo apoyos y optó por el
periodismo esto de alguna forma me
desmotivó mientras que algunas amigas y
colegas viajaban a hawai a indonesia
participaban en eventos fuera de brasil
yo no tuve este soporte financiero en
aquella época pero para luchar contra la
discriminación en 2019 creó el
movimiento de surfistas negras he creado
una página en instagram una plataforma
gratuita donde comencé a publicar fotos
de mujeres negras para que estas mujeres
sean vistas y para que se conecten entre
ellas desde las redes sociales
erika intentad es construir el
estereotipo de los surfistas rubios y
erradicar lo que define como racismo
estructural con esto llegamos al final
de las noticias en france 24 más
información en france 24 punto com
también en las redes sociales y en la
app siga con nuestra programación buenas
noches
[Música]